economía en directo américa de france 24
y ya está conmigo la pitón usa la divina
el hablando porque lenguas y daniela
porque lo estábamos conversando usted
dijo que efectivamente toda esta
polémica con disney iba a ser la noticia
de la semana y vea la noticia económica
de la semana raúl y cada día van
surgiendo más y más cosas de una bola de
nieve vamos a averiguar en qué para esto
y qué le espera entonces es distinto a
la posible pérdida de este estatus
especial que tiene el estado de la
florida donde opera pues el grueso de su
parque es walt disney world
claro pues recordemos primero
rápidamente que el gobernador ron de
santis se enfrenta con uno de los
mayores empleadores financiadores de su
estado que es walt disney que es a su
vez una corporación que antes de la
pandemia atraía raúl anote los 70
millones de visitantes por año y
empleaba alrededor de 80 mil personas
ahora las cifras han bajado un poco hace
más de medio siglo walt disney operan
como distrito especial es decir que
gobierna sobre un área de unos 100
kilómetros cuadrados y esta área está
compuesta por parques temáticos hoteles
campos de golf y otros lugares de
entretenimiento
danny que está en juego entonces para
disney pues los impuestos que paga hoy
disney los paga al distrito de
mejoramiento de reedy creek y a los
condados de osceola y este distrito a su
vez brinda servicios como bomberos
medicinas tratamiento de aguas
alcantarillado
inclusive tiene está su propia policía
también puede emitir bonos municipales
esto qué quiere decir que capta dinero
de inversionistas para financiarse todo
eso podría perderlo desde el 2023
probablemente disney va a responder una
demanda la legislatura de florida junto
con el gobernador tiene tal vez que
refinar lo que se hizo pero hay un
riesgo que sea del que se ha venido
hablando evidente que disney tiene bonos
que han emitido como una municipalidad
normal por el orden de los mil millones
de dólares para hacer ciertos
desarrollos y se dice de que de la
manera que esto se ha hecho ahora
podrían ser los ciudadanos de la florida
lo que tiene que pagar esos impuestos
que eran esos bonos que eran
responsabilidad
danny seguimos con otra noticia de la
semana porque el mos ya dice que tiene
todo el dinero para comprar twitter en
su totalidad ajá y es que él sigue
interesado con quedarse con el 100% de
la empresa lo que sería la adquisición
más grande propuesta por una persona en
la historia bursátil
el multimillonario ya dijo en una
presentación a los reguladores de eeuu
que más de dos tercios de esos cuarenta
y seis mil 500 millones de dólares en
que está valorado el negocio provendrán
de sus propios activos y que el resto lo
conseguirá con deuda que va a respaldar
con el mismo twitter pero no está claro
raúl qué tan dispuesto estaría la banca
para asumir el riesgo de semejante monto
y más aún cuando el mismo el mismo hilo
nos ha insinuado que podría alejar a
twitter de la publicidad de la que
depende en mayor parte su ingreso con el
que pagaría podrían entonces acudir a su
empresa de los huevitos de oro hablamos
de test la claridad es que de hecho la
mayor parte de la riqueza de dillon más
que está vinculada a las acciones del
fabricante de vehículos de lujo así que
si echara mano de su participación
agotaría liquidez de la que dispone
aunque también hay que tener en cuenta
que esa empresa pasa por un momento
extraordinario le voy a mostrar las
cifras en el primer trimestre casi que
duplicó sus impuestos sus ingresos
perdón a más de 18 mil millones de
dólares frente al mismo período del año
pasado y las ganancias fueron seis veces
superiores de hecho hoy está produciendo
70 por ciento más vehículos que el año
pasado para esta misma época les está
yendo muy bien muy bien claro que
belleza de carros la verdad que sí está
ni cambiar nuevamente de tema porque
rusia comenzó las pruebas para apostarle
a un rublo digital esto a lo mejor para
paliar toda esta crisis que se ve con la
sanción exactamente y es que con las
sanciones occidentales que excluyen a
este país de gran parte del sistema
financiero mundial ahora moscú está
buscando formas alternativas de realizar
pagos tanto en el país como en el
extranjero por eso el banco central
espera poner en marcha desde 2023 un
rublo digital y también busca que más
países acepten las tarjetas emitidas por
el banco central como alternativa a visa
ya mastercard que son dos franquicias
que se unieron a este boicoteó
occidental y que suspendieron sus
operaciones en rusia lo que también hay
que decir raúl es que este es un
proyecto de varios países del mundo no
solamente de rusia y ellos buscan no
sólo modernizar el sistema financiero
sino evitar lo que consideran una
amenaza de las cripto monedas que llevan
ya varios años tomando auge bueno todo
puede pasar en esta guerra y en este
desarrollo danny gracias nos vemos más
adelante con más economía en directo
américa y pasamos ahora revista de
prensa saludamos a rosa pérez más de
eeuu